hello and welcome to this video on edge
AI for artificial intelligence if you
are interested in learning more about
how AI is revolutionizing the world
around us this video is for you AI is a
New Concept in the world of AI that
refers to devices and sensors at the
edge of the network they can collect and
process data in real time
this allows for faster more accurate
decision making and greater efficiency
in a variety of applications such as
self-driving Vehicles Smart Homes and
health monitoring so how is AGI
different from cloud computing and cloud
computing AI the main difference is the
location where the data is processed LGA
enables devices at the edge of the
network to process data locally without
having to send it to the cloud this can
lead to faster more responsive systems
and can help you preserve bandwidth and
reduce latency in contrast cloud
computing AI processes data in the cloud
where it can assess vast amount of data
and compute resources but also requires
a reliable internet connection and can
be slow as AGI becomes more advanced it
has the potential to transform many
Industries such as Healthcare
Transportation manufacturing and a lot
it can enable new applications such as
autonomous vehicles remote surgery and
real-time monitoring of machines and
equipments while cloud computing AI has
many benefits AGI offers the advantages
of faster decision making reduced
latency and improve efficiency so if you
are interested in learning more about
the future of AI Aji is definitely a
topic worth exploring on that note hello
everyone and welcome to Simply learn in
today's video we'll understand what Edge
Computing is and how it is different
from traditional cloud computing but
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our channel to stay updated with all
the latest Technologies and hit that
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
us so without any further delay let's
get started but wait if you want to
become an expert in Edge Computing then
look no further than calcium in machine
learning offered by simply learn which
is an online program designed to provide
students with a comprehensive
understanding of AI and machine learning
Concepts tools and techniques this
program is created in collaboration with
caltex ctme and IBM and it is designed
to provide Learners with a strong
foundation in Ai and machine learning
Concepts this program covers various
topics such as data science statistics
deep learning computer vision and NLP
and help you gain the right skill set on
various tools such as care as matpatlib
tensorflow Django and many more
furthermore the curriculum is structured
around interactive online classes live
sessions with industry experts and
Hands-On projects so why wait hurry up
enroll now and Caltech postgraduate
program in a and machine learning and
create your own successful career link
is added in the description box below so
make sure you check that out so without
any further Ado let's jump directly into
our today's topic so firstly let us
understand what is Edge Computing the
term Edge Computing for AI refers to the
process of running air computations and
processing close to the data source or
Edge devices at the edge of a network as
opposed to relying on centralized
cloud-based servers in order to enable
real-time data analysis pick a response
times and a decreased Reliance on cloud
infrastructure it deploys AI models and
algorithms directly on edge devices or
local servers
here it's Computing typically entails
the deployment of lightweight AI models
designed to use on edge devices with
constrained computational power then
these models are frequently deployed to
the edge after being trained using
cloud-based resources The Edge devices
gather data from their sensors or from
outside sources process the data locally
using the a models that have been
deployed and give prompt responses or
start processes based on the data but
water to the rise of Hai well with rapid
advancement in technology in every
sector and businesses are looking to
increase automation to increase workflow
productivity and security and for that
computer programs must be able to
identify patterns and Carry Out tasks
repeatedly and safely in order to assist
people now the range of tasks that human
perform however covers different
situations that are impossible to fully
describe in quotes and rules because the
world is very unstructured well with the
help of developments in Hai machines and
gadgets can Now function with the
intelligence of human cognition whenever
they may be smart applications with AI
capabilities can learn to carry out the
same tasks under various conditions just
like in real life and here are the three
recent innovations that explain why
using AI models at the edge is on the
rise well first on the list we have
advancement of neural networks now over
the years as you know neural networks
and related AI infrastructure have
advanced unmatured allowing for more
generalized machine learning
capabilities this means organizations
have to gain a deeper understanding on
how to train a models effectively and
deploy them in production at the edge
development in computational
infrastructure now running AI at the
edge requires substantial computational
power the field has witnessed notable
advancements in computational
infrastructure to support AI at the edge
particularly recent strikes in highly
parallel graphic processing units or
gpus and CPUs have enabled efficient
execution of neural networks gpus are
specifically designed to handle complex
parallel computation making them a
suitable choice of processing Ai
workloads and finally widespread usage
of iot devices now the widespread
adoption of Internet of thing devices
has generated vast amounts of data these
devices such as industrial sensors smart
cameras and Robotics provide a rich
source of data that can be utilized for
AI analysis at the edge the availability
of diverse iot devices and their ability
to capture real-time data has
facilitated the deployment of AI models
at the edge but why deploy AI at the
edge what are the benefits of edge
Computing now Edge Computing for AI
addresses the limitations and challenges
associated with conventional cloud
generic AI methods so here are some of
the advantages which it offers firstly
decreased latency Now by performing AI
processing at the edge there is a
significant reduction in network latency
since data no longer needs to be
transmitted to the cloud and back this
is particularly beneficial for
applications that demand real-time
responses or decision making let's say
like autonomous vehicles or Industrial
Automation secondly real-time data
analysis it's Computing for AI enables
emea data analysis and inference
directly on the edge devices themselves
this is especially valuable for time
sensitive applications that require
real-time insights or predictions
eliminating the need for Reliance on
cloud connectivity
enhance privacy and security well Edge
Computing enhances privacy and security
by keeping data and air processing local
sensitive information can be processed
on the edge devices without being
transmitted to the cloud minimizing the
risk of data breaches and ensuring
compliance with data privacy regulations
next we have bandwidth optimization Edge
Computing reduces the volume of data
that needs to be transmitted to the
cloud sending only relevant or let's say
summarized data now this optimization
minimizes bandwidth requirements reduces
Network cost and even lightens the load
on the cloud infrastructure in total and
finally it offers offline functionality
Edge Computing enables a models to
function even in situation which limited
or no internet connectivity this
capability is crucial for scenarios that
require continuous operation in remote
or disconnected environments such as
certain iot applications or field
deployments so these were some of the
reasons why we need to deploy AI at the
edge and the benefit it's offering now
comes the main question how exactly does
Edge Computing works well Edge Computing
is primarily focused on the proximity
and location of data processing and
storage the fundamental principle is
simple then it's not feasible to bring
data to a centralized data center the
alternative is to bring the data center
close to the data now in order to enable
machines to perform tasks like let's say
a visual perception object detection
driving cars understanding speech
speaking walking and emulating other
human skills they need to replicate
human intelligence in a functional
manner so for that AI uses a deep neural
network as a data structure to emulate
human cognition these dnns undergo
training in data centers are exposed to
numerous examples of specific tasks or
question type along with their correct
answer and once the training is complete
the model advances to become a inference
engine capable of addressing real world
questions now from there on here's how
it typically Works firstly deployment
kind of inference engine now in AJ
deployments the inferencing Gen which is
the component responsible for making
predictions or performing AI tasks is
deployed on local computers or devices
located in device environments like
factories hospitals cars satellites
homes and much more
problem identification and data upload
now while the inference engine operates
at the edge it may encounter situation
where it struggles to provide accurate
predictions or encounter challenging
scenarios in such cases the problematic
data associated with these instances is
commonly identified and applied to a
centralized Cloud structure now from
there on there is a continuous
cloud-based model training now the cloud
infrastructure typically in a data
center receives the problematic data
from Edge devices data scientists and AI
experts can then utilize this data to
refine and train the original a models
further this involves using the clouds
computational resources larger data sets
and collaboration tools for model
training and Improvement now and finally
with the updated model deployed at the
edge after being retrained the AI system
continues to operate gaining new data
and insights from its environment the
Aja model can collect further additional
data which can be periodically uploaded
to the cloud and further training and
continuous Improvement this feedback
loops enjoy that the AGI models become
progressively smarter over time so this
is in a nutshell how Edge Computing for
AI Works hope you have understood well
let us talk some of the use cases of
edge Computing for AI in real world well
the combination of AI iot and Edge
Computing has opened up a multitude of
opportunities for Edge AI
revolutionizing the various aspects of
our daily lives so let's delve into some
key areas where Edge AI is making a
significant impact first on the list we
have Healthcare Hai is enhancing medical
Diagnostics and patient care for
instance by deploying AI algorithms on
medical imaging devices Radiologists can
accurately and efficiently identify and
analyze pathologies wearable devices
with local Edge analytics enable
real-time monitoring of patient data
facilitating any early detection of
anomalies And Timely interventions
next autonomous vehicles Edge air plays
a pivotal role in enabling real-time
navigation and decision making for
autonomous vehicles a algorithms running
on edge devices within Vehicles process
sensor data analyze the environment and
make Split Second decisions to ensure
safe and efficient driving
agriculture hji is being used to address
agriculture challenges as well such as
pollination autonomous drones equipped
with Hai capabilities can identify and
pollinate plants aiding in crop
cultivation and maximizing yields this
application demonstrates the diverse
potential of edge AI Beyond traditional
domains next we have smart home and
cities now Edge AI enhances the
functionality and efficiency of Smart
Homes and cities local processing and
Analysis of data from iot devices enable
real-time automation Energy Management
security surveillance and personalized
user experience hji power system adapt
to individual preferences optimized
resources usage and respond to events in
real time
next we have industrial applications
Edge AI is transforming Industries
thoroughly through real-time monitoring
predictive maintenance and process
optimization Edge devices equipped with
AI algorithms analyze sensor data detect
anomalies and predict equipment failures
reducing downtime and improving
efficiency
next we have security and surveillance
well AJ placed a crucial role in
security and surveillance which Empires
real-time video analytics for security
and surveillance applications Edge
devices with a capabilities can analyze
video feeds locally detect suspicious
activities like theft identify objects
or individuals of interest and Trigger
alerts or responses enhancing security
measures and reducing response types
finally we have personal devices Hai is
increasingly being integrated into
personal devices such as your
smartphones laptops variables and smart
home assistants this allows for
on-device a processing enabling faster
and more personalized experience without
relying heavily on cloud connectivity
which can support voice recognition
facial recognition among other features
as well well as more businesses and
industries recognize the advantage of
Hai its adoption is rapidly growing the
ability to process data locally enhance
privacy reduce latency and make
real-time decision impulse organizations
in various sectors to enhance operations
deliver better services and improve user
experience so these are some of the
real-time applications of agile and with
that we've come to the end of today's
session on what it's Computing for AIS I
hope you understood thank you for
watching the video guys if you found
this tutorial informative and helpful
give it a thumbs up and share it with
your friends and colleagues if you have
any further queries regarding any of the
the concepts are topics out in today's
tutorial feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and a team of
experts will be more than happy to help
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time stay safe thank you and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you